cacti are perpetual victims and kitten
heart it's episode 34 of IMG when these
guys get busy you get this and when
adobe adds the force to Photoshop you
get Adobe Wan kenobe if other brands did
the same we'd have Jedi
dude or do not sit puma punch it your
way or Jabba the Hutt there's a smiley
face on the surface of Mars and
starburst region NGC 3603 is the same
wedding photography can be mobi packing
enough heat to warm the bun in the oven
a chair with in a chair with in a chair
with in a chair chair ception
a tree chair and an ergonomic really
let's move on to a kitten with a
permanent top hat and some lesser-known
last suppers Popeye cartoons Team
Fortress 2 other videogame characters
and zombies if you're not hungry skip
the supper and just grab a drink from
Fremont coffee with foam shaped into
Batman Darth Vader Frank from Donnie
Darko or Pikachu though of course I
prefer Cthulhu chew they also have boba
fett but I prefer girls dressed as boba
fett enjoy
[Music]
[Applause]
the more action checkup josh mcs disney
princess fighters Ariel Belle Jasmine
snow-white and more thanks to Moe luge
INSCOM here is some neon vomit stare at
the black dot in the middle and no
matter what don't move your eyes slowly
but surely the surrounding colors will
disappear into the gray get its Tiger
designs alphabetical food posters if you
look closely you'll get it all over your
face these pictures come from its upand
Ogoni
and finding them this week made my week
on facebook.com slash vsauce gaming
frederic showed us an example of bad
cd-rom design and Caleb's image of
perfectly round circles hurt my brain to
try to understand finally baaaad gave us
these important acronyms and I'm not
done there click this to watch Vsauce 2
episode of loop which is just like this
show but you can buy everything on it be
sure to subscribe to Vsauce to keep the
party going and like us on Facebook to
show your friends that you have good
taste most importantly no matter who you
are or what you do remember that as
always thanks for watching
you